[Musique]
ouais enfin alors que la situation
sanitaire ne s'arrange pas de plus en
plus de français craquent et enfreignent
les règles sanitaires en organisant des
fêtes géantes un peu partout en france
leur façon d'exprimer un ras-le-bol
général du rpt a besoin de sortir mardi
soir ce sont les images de 300 fêtards
déchaîné près de la saône qui a fait le
tour des réseaux sociaux
les français bien décidés à s'amuser au
mépris de tous les gestes barrière au
même moment à lille c'est au jardin
vauban que 400 personnes s'étaient donné
rendez vous pour prendre l'apéro et
danser même après les heures du
couvre-feu dépasser les policiers sur
place ont tenté le dialogue plutôt que
la force des citoyens qui n'en peuvent
plus alors faites clandestine xxl la
rébellion des français est elle
justifiée
merci merci à vous trois d'être là merci
à louis brouillard merci merci d'être là
vous êtes étudiant bruno attal policiers
merci bruno vous étudiez venu nous voir
là bas ils vont m'avait lancé un défi
que je vais relever ce qui m'a dit de
suivre ma dit quoi c'est quoi des
finances vous allez mettre une tenue de
policier est un masque et puis on va
aller un peu contrôlés on va voir un peu
près ce que c'est là le métier de rexel
d'accord un vrai film on peut filmer ont
comme ça nous regarde et caméras il y
aura le coffre c'est ça faire du buzz
pour vous sinon n'a pas besoin pour
l'instant genre les autorisations on n'a
pas de réussite pour nous faire du buzz
c'est l'ancien humoriste et puis on a
brisé participants à la fête de lyon
mabri s'est alors on est bien peignés on
est tous à l'oreille breasseale en
revenir au bruit mais là c'est une case
de la moto
ah ouais mais c'est très bien j'aime
dire çà doit dire alors c'est vers ça
les chiffres et on a vu ces images on va
voir des images de ce qui s'est passé
hier à lyon à 19h heures du couvre feu
des centaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées sur le quai saint-antoine
peu ou pas de masque pas de
distanciation sociale les gestes
barrière loin d'être respectée et c'est
vrai alors est ce que vous comprenez la
rébellion des jeunes par ou bien vous
dit non c'est pas possible et en en ont
poussé a lâché entre les deux parce que
je comprends et je connais je suis
toujours pas d'accord il ya entre les
deux bref entre les deux stars je
comprends que les gens soient énervés
maintenant il ya une décision à prendre
urgemment qui est de confiner la france
et que les gens ne puissent pas faire ce
genre de choses et à 5072 personnes
aujourd'hui en réanimation où on
recommence oui mais c'est toujours bien
on va voir les images
[Musique]
alors delphine jamais d'accord en fait
on rêve tous de faire ça mais si toute
la france si toute la jeunesse faisait
ça on n'en sortirait pas que cette
pandémie au bout d'un moment il faut
hockey être frustré mais être frustré
tous ensemble pour qu'on en sorte
parce que là c'est cool vous avez passé
un bon moment mais au final vous savez
pas les répercussions de cette fête
alors qu'est ce t'en penses quoi brice
qui a participé à cette fête
bah moi je pense que ça fait vraiment du
bien de sortir parce que on est toujours
à la maison on travaille tout le temps
là on s'est dit bon il fait chaud on
sort ça fait du bien mais heureusement
on dit quoi vos parents hésité pour il
était contre c'est des cons il était
d'accord
ouais et ta grand-mère de ce mois
allez sortez sortez ah bah non madame je
pose une question sahraouie parce que
oui parce que pour après c'est vrai non
mais c'est vrai que oui
après forcément pour le jeu que vous
avez un tel bonheur et oui non ni avant
la fête ni après la fin je n'ai jamais
fait d'accord avec toi tu sais pas si
vous êtes vous regrettez aujourd'hui
pas du tout un petit peu c'est vrai je
mets un petit peu parce que je me dis
c'est bien mais c'est contre parce que
c'est bien on sort tous ensemble on
s'amuse et ses comptes parce qu'on sait
qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
personnes qui sont réanimation alors que
j'assure et vous avez craqué en a eu
marre j'en avais marre et ça amuse
musées 25 degrés à lyon et c'est
commencer tellement vous êtes réunis
c'est quoi l'histoire c'est à dire on
serre et maintenant me mois de bataille
avec un pote on sortait sur les quais
à bouger et on a vu un attroupement de
personnes et on s'est dit pourquoi pas y
aller on s'est mis dans quoi alors on va
voir la vidéo de brice dans un instant
et bruno bien sûr attal d'un policier
guillaume vous vous êtes d'accord avec
avec je suis d'accord et c'est lorsque
j'étais à lyon ce week-end
exactement à cet endroit là en fait ce
qui a changé la sécu à de la musique
parce qu'il ya tout le monde sur les
quais même un pari personne est confiné
les gens sont dans la rue il ya de moins
en moins de gens qui portent le masque
et attention ne vous trompez pas c'est
pas la seule fête avec des gens en ce
moment il ya plein de jeunes qui font la
fête le week-end à présent bien ils n'en
peuvent plus qui c'est naïf pour croire
franchement que les jeunes là alors je
parle pas au nom de tous les jeunes
parce qu'un hacker respecte les gestes
mais sont confinés sagement depuis un an
et reste chez nous tout seuls le soir
bord dans des petits studios mais
attendez mais vous rêvez ou quoi bruno
quand vous entendez ça ben j'ai eu 20
ans aussi moi aussi j'ai envie d'aller
avec eux faire la fête ya pas de
problème hein ça mais ils se rendent pas
compte enfin ils ont joué ils ont 20 ans
ils sont jeunes et ils se rendent pas
compte que voilà par exemple si les
policiers devaient intervenir à
intervenir là bon heureusement que sont
pas intervenus mais c'est dangereux de
tous mes collègues pour ces jeunes pour
leurs parents pour on va parler aussi
peut-être des infirmières on va parler
de mains de gens qui soit mais ils ont
20 ans et voilà et moi j'ai pas envie
d'être contre les jeunes ce soir je les
comprends mais voilà moi je
fonctionnaires de police et voilà vous
on est dans un état républicain vous
commettez des infractions c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué de mettre des
amendes à des jeunes comme ça on y est
alors on n'y a pas été tout simplement
parce que ben il ya un vrai danger bon
en plus il ya la jurisprudence de nantou
où il ya une personne qui est tombée
alors on vend des contrats légalement
enfin en plus ça picole voilà j'ai pas
envie d'être le père fouettard et
charles darrow et leur dire c'est pas
bien mais voilà moi je fonctionnaires de
police je vois mes collègues qui
emploient de plus qui sont crevés et on
voit ça enfin voilà ça c'est dur ça doit
être compliqué aussi pour vous de se
dire allez là dessus c'est compliqué de
réprimander des jeunes quand on dit
voilà on se dit bon c'est vrai qu'ils
c'est vrai qu'ils sont hors la loi en ce
moment mais c'est vrai qu'on se dit il
ils font rien de mal si on n'était pas
en période de de confinement et c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué d'aller quand
même ce que j'aime pas c'est quoi
hiérarchise hier ashes la douleur
c'étaient les jeunes souffrent ok mais
il ya beaucoup de gens qui souffrent
toujours dire que mes collègues
voilà on est on est au bord du gouffre
on est fatigué encore une fois que j'ai
parlé des infirmières mais on souffre
tous donc mais ils ont vingt ans
maintenant moi voilà je peux pas être
complaisant avec ça mais après pareille
nos gouvernants fâche pas c'est du grand
n'importe quoi puisqu'il autorise des
manifestations on peut être entassés
dans des trains des trucs comme ça donc
les banques comprennent pas donc
alors il ya l'adjointe santé à la mairie
de lyon qui avait twitté
nous comprenons la lassitude causés par
la situation sanitaire
mais nous devons comprendre le danger
que représente ce genre d'événements non
déclarés d'autant plus quand il est fait
sans aucun respect des gestes barrières
et l'absence du port du masque brice on
l'a entendue donc je vous raconte louis
étudiant louis qu'est ce t'en penses
quoi
bah en fait ce que tu iras une fête
comme ça moi j'irais pas une fête comme
ça mais parfait et je pense pas que ce
soit intelligent de le faire par edouard
je peux pas leur dire ce que vous avez
fait c'est mal je peux que les
comprendre parce que il ya trois mois il
y avait un drama général en dix ans les
étudiants les jeunes à la la qu'est-ce
qui souffrent on a fait tout le monde
était d'accord et il ya encore un peu de
cette compassion ici mais en fait le
débat il est pas entre les jeunes et les
policiers
le débat il est entre les jeunes et les
dirigeants macro pourrait dire aux
jeunes ne sortait pas vous pourriez même
mettre des amendes aux jeunes et
continuerait de sortir c'est c'est
humain c'est comme ça et en fait on a
des jeunes qui veulent sortir et qui
sont pas protégés alors on peut faire
quelque chose
par exemple pourquoi est ce que les
mairies ne réquisitionne pas des parcs
ils prennent tous les gens qui sont des
surveillants la sécurité des festivals
qui songe aujourd'hui au chômage
technique
il les dit il les paye et ils disent
voilà tu as un carré blanc dans
lesquelles les jeunes peuvent boire des
bières à un mètre de distance et vous
surveiller tout le reste du parc où les
jeunes y portent des masques
en fait le problème c'est que les gens
vont sortir qui est des lois ou qu'ils
aient des amendes maïoroff d'une hydre
organisée là là là c'est une dictature
dans ces cas là sion part que les gens à
tel endroit etc
voilà vous êtes là on vous mais là je
pense pas que les jeunes accepté
si jamais si jamais il y avait une
organisation qui lui permettait de tout
ce protégé de se réguler je vous jure
qu'il le ferait pas ce que la la en
sortant sa ils flippent pour leur grand
mère marie d'ailleurs c'est même ce
qu'il dit il flippe ce que demande
attestée pardon excusez moi y mc logique
mais qui paie pas je veux pas moi j'ai
pas de leçon de réalisme à vous donner
mais malgré tout vous avez des parents
vous êtes rentré vous à ne pas tester si
vous êtes asymptomatiques vous êtes un
risque donc non on flippe l'ont fait pas
vraiment non plus quoi tu peux aller bah
oui mais à ce moment là il fait il faut
être cohérent il faut aller au bout de
sa logique moi je comprends à
l'exaspération à tout ça et là très bien
entre guillaume
mais pourquoi pas ce moment la rentrée
s'isoler mettre un masque se tester
faire un tout petit peu gaffe quoi parce
que sinon le nom mais c'est pas possible
enfin mozilla dans des ronds enfin tu
vas boire une bière avec des potes voilà
vous avez vous forcément vous avez vous
allez voir des religions mais l'affairé
dernier les festivals ça marchait comme
ça j'en ai fait et la sécurité c'est son
travail elle sait le faire
le problème c'est que les dirigeants ne
comprennent pas que les gens vont sortir
et ont besoin de sortir
et puisqu'ils disent vous n'avez pas le
droit mais en fait les gens se voient
clandestinement et du coup on n'organise
rien on ne protège rien ni personne et
comme comme ça a été dit ça va se
reproduire
du coup on fait le choix est ce qu on
les bloque tout sur le plateau et ça
changera rien ou est ce qu'on décide
d'organiser ces espaces de socialisation
il ya une solution et une autre qui m'a
rappelé mon avenir mais il reste deux
mois à tenir elle apprend à tous la fête
et situation bac ça va s'accélérer
il faut tenir on va voir un message
d'espoir comme ça on en chie tous et je
peux vous dire qu'on envoie moi j'avais
de sortir j'ai mon frère qui est à
l'autre bout du monde j'ai pas vu depuis
un an et demi on en chie tous donc voilà
vous êtes jeunes moi je vous êtes chauds
bouillants mois 20 ans je sais pas si
j'aurai tout comme vous aussi nous voilà
mais vous êtes chauds bouillants essayé
de tenir presque toi ce que tu dis là
bon il ya plein de jeunes qui disent oui
on va le faire on va le faire